Chinese governments in the horizon 2020
research program caresses is developing
the world's first culturally aware
robots aimed at assisting and caring for
the elderly assistance intelligent
robots for older people could relieve
pressure in hospitals and care homes as
well as improved the care delivery at
home and promote the independent living
for the elderly people in order for
robots to be more acceptable to older
people it is essential that they can be
programmed to adapt to diverse
backgrounds the project will expand my
capabilities and aims to reduce pressure
on health care services it also has the
potential to boost independence reduce
loneliness and improve the quality of
life among elderly people Peppa how have
you been helping middle sexes outreach
work I also play a major role in
Middlesex University stem outreach
activity for example in September I
worked alongside 94 Middlesex University
staff and students at the new scientist
lab exhibition I met hundreds of young
people there and helped to get them
excited about the future technology in
science we also have an annual stand
Festival on campus for students parents
and the whole community at Middlesex we
put a lot of effort into engaging our
students with their discipline in an
authentic way we give them the
opportunity to translate their work to a
wider public through stem outreach work
what is the role for humans in the
fourth Industrial Revolution robots will
have an important role to play but we
will always need the soft skills that
are the meek to humans to sense make and
try value from technology as
technologies fused and are used in ways
that were not envisage before a new way
of thinking is needed by tomorrow's
workers we will need people who can
spawn the ideas and think across
traditional sector divides to drive
value from technological innovation how
can robots help students learn in the
classroom at Middlesex University I work
closely on projects with final-year
students from robotics psychology buy
your medicine and education students
program me to engage with audience and a
range of environments and social
settings for example Joanna and I are
working together to adapt my interfaces
to work with primary school children
with or without special needs to develop
their numeracy skills Joanna can give
you further information about this
project Thank You pepper to give a round
of applause to pepper under stood raised
[Applause]
thank you start off very quickly with
Lucy before I come on
to William and first of all pepper I
just want to say better than some of the
ministers you've had before and perhaps
the universities in Mattoon you could
tell us about the work you've done
working alongside pepper and how you
develop your skills in doing that okay
so pepper is extra cutely curricular to
to our course but it's there for
everyone to learn we use them a lot like
like itself too for our events so stem
festivals new scientists live world
skills show in a way to just promote
stem to to the public especially to
children because they're obviously very
interested bye bye bye pepper during the
summer I've been working on this project
so pepper can start going to primary
schools and teach little kids how to do
simple math so just like counting one to
twenty shapes simple multiplication or
simple something just just to see if
it's more interesting for for children
and if they they're more interested in
the subject when they have something
completely new than just doing it with
the teacher or doing it with games on
the tablet so yeah we're gonna test that
very soon but I've tested it with my
cousins and and they enjoyed it very
much so just ask you you computer
science students third year and I'm
studying robotics engineering I'm in my
third year to further the rest of the
panel really you're talking about the
the math program that you're running
in primary schools does that extend
beyond computation to problem-solving in
critical thinking and and where where
are we ought to internment for the
technology to achieve that technology is
difficult because the term AI is when I
started a long long time ago in the
computing industry AI basically was used
to mean anything that was too hard to do
really so for example computer vision
was artificial intelligence speech
recognition speech synthesis object
recognition all of the things that we
now take for granted on our mobile
phones was all AI so it's a moving
target I think one of the things that
often people forget is it AI isn't
something that it's going to happen it's
something that will develop because will
constantly rename something ai when we
want it to happen I think the comment
was made in the earlier panel about well
we still need computer science well
that's a very interesting question
because I think of all the subjects
computer science is probably the one
that will go on forever because the more
imagination you have the more things you
think to do with computing and more
computing changes so in terms of where
we are with the technology what can we
do with pepper in a school there's all
sorts of areas where we could work a lot
of it relates to what sensors we have
what sort of things we want to do how
invasive we want to be so we could for
example start using brain computer
interaction to collect data do we want
to do that I'm not sure that may be a
step too far I think there's a whole
rich tapestry out there are things we
could do what we do what you'll end up
doing I think quite rightly should be
driven by education lists and teachers
so that in mind are there any particular
skills that those teachers need to
develop
so I think the teachers more than
anything I mean I used to be I put my
cards on the table I started in like my
career as a math teacher so I've been
there and thoroughly enjoyed it and I
think the point about the skills that
teachers need I think going forward will
be the same skills that the students
need which is agility flexibility etc
and I think they need a framework within
they can do those things
any other members of the panel wish to
add to that just some time ago out the I
was asked to go to a college in North
London and talk about integration
differentiation to a group of youngsters
who could not care less about maths and
just to just to motivate them and and I
thought it had been 20 years and so I
studied those and to be honest with you
I couldn't even spell those so I said
can I just do it my own way
and we took some some equipment and we
equipment runs on compressed air we had
to look at four cents an area and
pressure and the fact that on a working
equipment we could relate these these
three together and actually show that in
order for this machine to work you have
to work out the force the pressure you
have to work out the area of the body of
the circle and then they are to look at
PI R squared majority of them could not
even raise it to the power of two and
then they realize that obviously that's
a skill that's it so what what I'm
saying is basically we managed what we
did was we put magnets into into into
the context of a of an industrial
example and and then within that within
that they have to look look at
percentages again none of them could do
it but the fact that he was there they
could they could feel it they could
touch it it was it was a real example it
it it made a massive massive difference
and we went from not serving any
interest at the beginning to almost not
being able to to ask them to to leave
so does that take it beyond
gimmick the house if you were to say not
just a means of engaging students is
that a deeper level of learning to be
had from it yes I mean if it could
there's a lot of subjects if we could
make them practical and show the show
the students at what is what are we what
are we getting out and and also seem
simplify it then there is a there will
be a lot a lot of lot of mileage in that
thank you I think that's a quick follow
up on there's a really important point
about pepper and other devices and
gimmicks and happy with the word gimmick
but the notion of embodied learning and
the work people like Peppard Montessori
tactile learning is an area of which
he's now very very interesting because
modern technology allows us to do things
which are tactile with sensory feedback
in ways which 25 30 years ago were quite
tricky when Peppard first suggested them
so give us an example of how that would
work in practice with students okay so
so for me and I think for the way we
work at Middlesex but the we take the
problem the problem as a prime the
problem is where the interesting
learning will take place so we work from
problems we want the students to be able
to relate to problems so what part did
with mathematics for example was to say
well rather than mathematics being
abstract up here let's put the student
in the place of mathematics so shape
becomes something that you walk around
something that you touch something that
you move around so with our math
students for example we do an awful lot
of model building with real physical
models to help them understand most
dimensional spaces so that tactile
notion the ability to take something
touch it sense it feel it is really
important so what pepper does if you
pepper apart from having face
recognition so it will engage it will
turn and look at you is it allows us to
say there's software in there so so for
many people computing is something you
do at a keyboard or the screen for our
students I hope that isn't the model at
all computing isn't about typing things
on a keyboard and having a screen
it's about your drive
car your fridge your shopping system
Google your phone your camera and I
think that the fourth Industrial
Revolution we're working very closely
with Festo and Siemens it is about
putting productivity up into the cloud
what does that mean
we haven't really worked that out yet
but it's approach I mean you set in a
really eloquent way and it's that is
affirming and celebrating - to the
summary but it seems at odds with the
social policy running throughout our
curriculum primary so HG doesn't yes I
mean I have to say I struggle with
things like removal of practical work in
silence as a decision to help people do
practical science and industry yeah do
you think our level system is too narrow
to and now and should be you should
cover but possibly have a perk laureate
at the age of 18 where you would move
GCC's to doing them at 18 and have
science creative if you want to do all
subjects and I wrestle with this because
I think there is a role for disciplines
there is a role for subjects but equally
going forward I think you have to ask
whether disciplines still exist going
forward
what is the distinction between
neuroscience and biomedical science and
mathematics the genomics project is
largely a lot of very clever
mathematicians and computer science
working with biologists and web
scientists to do very interesting things
I'm not sure we helped students to
understand the world if we go do that do
that do that don't do that and do a
three-hour exam so just be clear I mean
earlier when are we talking about
computer science I didn't mean it could
be sighs will be obsolete I mean the
current curriculum it's so fast moving
and how do we do that so just to be
clear I mean your view as a university
is it the direction of travel of our
curriculum into very strongly academic
rote learning knowledge-based individual
disciplines is the wrong direction of
travel to meet the a actually yes
absolutely that doesn't mean there isn't
a role for people who are very clever
intellectually as well yeah but it
certainly isn't that for me the
overarching paradigm that works and some
people have said to me about AI that
actually what we need is not so much
more programmers or more people who are
computer literate but those that have
got the creative skills the kind of
psychology know how to sort of bring
that into the mix about how AI can be
better absorbed and yeah it's not an
either/or you need you need that
spectrum as yes so yes you need your
computer programmers to understand
psychology
take a cybersecurity is a classic
example if you teach
take cybersecurity as a purely technical
discipline you develop wonderful system
so forget the fact that most people
still put their passwords on a post-it
on the fridge at all and if you do that
you're not tackling security you
mentioned the baccalaureate I came to
the UK in in 19 1983 NSA as a youngster
and I came from black background of
doing doing 12 or 14 subjects in one go
to having to choose to choose a three
which at the time was was a levels of
syllables but then I was I was
introduced to baccalaureate which which
made life much easier for me because I
managed to do science on one side and
then Business Economics and languages
only on the other and it was a it was a
nice noise enraged balance of different
different subjects and funny laugh both
my children ended up doing baccalaureate
it's not nothing to do with me but
they've done they've done quite quite
well out of it again because of the of
the range of the subjects available to
them and that in the context of industry
for is very relevant because we're now
talking about a technology that cuts
across many many disciplines not just
not just engineering we're talking about
IT business you you Navy it it it's it
it has it has an impact on that
just finally before I pass over to my
colleague and would you include thick
that expansion at university as well so
rather than just doing as I did for
example just a politics degree would you
say that degree should have much wider
subjects that somebody made bear to
concentrate on a particular subject but
they would have to do the other ones
whether there was a deficit in so I
think I'll turn that model around and
say why should a university decide or
even a society decide what someone
should be taught what we should look at
are what problems do we need to solve to
me so if for example politicians the to
solve complex big data problems then I
will argue that politicians probably
need to do some data science and that
should come out of the problem it
shouldn't be I did a politics degree and
I've nothing against early bring us on
as a matter degree so I do have some
sympathy with these various subjects but
where you can see the synergies and I
think as you get older you start to see
that history for me is about making
sense of quite complex data it actually
isn't that difficult different to
computer science in many ways it's about
making sense of data in complicated
scenarios and I think that's what we
need people start doing at a much
younger age
hopefully asked units start to do and
just take us back to the classroom and
the role of pepper there in that as a
former teacher and it goes without
saying that I know for every primary
child pepper would be a master
and what we talked in the earlier
session about the barriers to the use of
AR for professionals someone put myself
back in that classroom as a teacher with
pepper in the morning 34 children
differentiation planning preparation all
of that what skills will only need to
have as a teacher to be able to work and
use and deploy pepper so the best for
the children and for the delivery of the
curriculum so canasa Nicholas and Joanna
how you see the teachers or what
barriers do will teachers have to
overcome or what would they need to know
and learn to be able to deploy so pepper
doesn't become a toy so the way I did
this project is that ever is very much
independent so she will need much
guidance much touching much anything so
the teacher is there obviously to help
the students and pepper is just it's
just a tool for the teacher so Pepper's
not gonna succeed or she's not gonna
take the teachers place she's just
another tool to make sure that the
learning is interesting could I just
suggest though that that tool could be
another challenge for a teacher in the
morning oh yeah it will be a challenge
as it is anything that is new to any
place but that's why we're gonna do some
tests and see how how it works but it
would definitely be a challenge but I
think I think if if the children were
really interested in the subject it
enriches
exactly it just becomes a flow between
teacher pepper or another robot with so
try to enrich the environment
I mean like I can see so many challenges
like classrooms with stairs in them with
steps in the network almost certainly
won't work because it there'll be all
those challenges however I would also
say that probably possibly not in early
years but certainly by yet by years five
or six levels five and six I think
there's probably gonna be children in
the room who say to the teacher actually
I'll get pre-program paper for you yeah
and I think that you'll find that the
children become a resource because where
as a teacher and as I say I would
struggle now going into a classroom with
pepper because I would have to get my
head around the technology I don't do
that I have students that do that
because they go oh yes it's just linking
to my phone you do this you do that and
so I think people will become part of a
learning community if we allowed it to
if we allowed controls to move from the
teacher to the classroom a little bit
more with all the problems that that
poses the teaching that we do sex offer
is very much very much practical and and
and skills based I've had the pleasure
of recruiting two graduates from
Middlesex and one graduate assistant
instructor and technologically they are
at a different different level and
especially with with industry for
because we have we have many learning
systems at different colleges and
universities and with these systems you
need you need in-depth training
unlike previous systems if something
plays off what goes wrong with these you
you you really need to know what
technologies there is and how to how to
tackle it and and these these guys have
been quite a quite an asset and they've
taken our business to a different level
not just on the technical techno
technological side but also business
minded their approach to customer
because although I'm part of a large
company what's only have a team of four
so when this gospel out to see a
customer they've got to be 100% focused
and represents the evolved eating or the
company Thank You Emma
thank you morning everybody and a couple
of things is before I go on to the
question I was really interested with
what you were saying Professor Martin
about starting with the problem because
I was listening to a speech just the
other night I'm apologies might say the
name one with Professor gotcha and he
was talking about how he's his soul as
his self-organized learning environments
and how he uses computers and technology
and how he starts everything with the
problem and he was arguing that people
by using computers can find the solution
to any problem and he posed a problem
which i thought was incredible to a
group of young people which was can be
in two places at the same time and find
out and the answers that the children
came back with were were remarkable so I
found that really interested in the
space of a few weeks I've had two
professors from different universities
telling me the same thing start with the
problem but I want to think particularly
to talk to particularly to Joanna and
Nikolas I want to think what do you
think are the key skills that students
will need in the future and do you agree
with the professor about you should be
starting with the problem rather than
individual subjects I can only really
speak from experience so as a computer
science student at Middlesex I've been
taught to be as diverse and adaptive as
I can be so say my second year we
learned about the fundamentals of web
development as such but if they expect
you to be able to roam into wider
territories than that I think it's like
blockchain AI robotics and I feel like I
came to use that adaptiveness when I did
my internship last year and I was
introduced to a blockchain project
blockchain beings
never done before and I was just asked
to figure it out
learn as much as I can and try and be
interactive in that project and I ended
up being fairly like fundamental to that
project I ended up contributing quite a
bit not because I knew blockchain
already but because I've been taught in
a way that helped me quickly adapt to a
new situation within why understand and
yeah yeah sorry no no no it's fine to me
if I just had a quick comment about one
of the problems was to make it became so
important to the company they didn't
want him to come back which of course
would have ironically been a disaster
for us because it would have hit our
continuation so I think there's an issue
here around progression and fortunately
Nick has come back but the company's
still paying him and yeah there's often
in a joking day a week for that company
and I have an offer after university as
well because they were has so happy with
the fact that I worked less than it less
of an intern more as a part of the team
yeah and they really appreciated that
what about you Jenna what what are the
key skills that you think students will
need in the future
definitely problem-solving definitely
being able to be autonomous and has Nick
said being adaptive to the situation
because technology I think the magic of
technology is you never know what's to
come you never know what people are
going to think of or develop and with
that you never know the problems that
are going to come so we know that as
Nick said some so if we don't know
what's coming we know that we have the
skill to go there explore and like okay
well know how to do
to solve the situation so definitely in
my course it's a it's a lot of autonomy
then we we have stored a lot of autonomy
so in one of my projects we had to
create a self balancing robot last year
and during the first year we had some
basic classes on the language language
that we were using but obviously as it
can imagine a self balancing orbit it's
something much more high and advanced
and with the basis our teachers and
lecturers just just give us just give us
the wings to go and explore but we have
to do it by ourselves so we have to be
very determined so so the big question I
think is how prepared were you at school
for going to university and doing the
course in the way that you've just
described did your school ever encourage
you to do these subjects and skills
study I studied in Portugal so I'm
originally from Portugal my high school
was very academic as academically as it
can get like many quizzes every week
tests every other week exams every every
final of the year end of the term with
nine books for exam just you know just
kind of putting the knowledge in and
forgetting everything the next day and I
I relate much more to the teaching here
because I actually learn well in my high
school I just kind of memorized
everything and then the next I was like
ooh I don't need any more I need my
memory space to my other exam in here
because we work on it ourselves
you really gets in there you just you
you get the knowledge in my a-levels I
did computing and the final project that
we had to do for the year it was just
they you decide what you're going to do
give a decent proposal for it and will
allow you to do whatever so that gave me
one of the starting points would be
learning about exploring and instead of
just being given a doing a looking out
seeing what I could do and then
attempting to do something like that so
for a level that was a good experience
of exploratory learning but with things
like maths obviously there's a very
straight curriculum and as Joanna said
you learn something remember it and then
regurgitate it and more than likely to
forget it afterwards because it's less
of an experience more of a task so how
could there be the better way to prepare
you for university what would you what
would you recommend differently it's a
better prepare you to work in the way
you need to work I feel like you rather
than being prepared for university being
I wouldn't say thrown in but jumping
into university and having different
experiences was very good for me because
it helped me realize like okay life
isn't just do tasks it is learning new
things and exploring which i think has
helped me in this next step jumping from
university into work so I can't think of
anything that I would change about my
a-levels as far as bridging between
Benin University
one of the the challenges I think we
face at Middlesex is the self esteem of
students it's a real challenge for the
universities that perhaps are not in the
elite Russell group where the students
are going tend to have a success behind
them they're coming in they are
successful they think they're successful
yeah we are often working with groups of
students that are coming in who have
kind of built up this culture of well
they're probably not gonna succeed in
things so they don't really want to take
risks and so we're very deliberate in
throwing our students into into quite
difficult situations I mean we took 90
students to New Scientist live which is
a big exhibition in Excel obviously look
at and it literally is like what like
coming in here really you know be walked
into this room where we saw the pit and
Johanna and I looked at each other and I
rates your problem because you know
that's that pit is a trap or pepper so
but you take 90 students to a blank huge
arena and we go okay in there will be
80,000 visitors coming around in about
four hours
get on with it and that really does
build teamwork but it also builds a
steep as self-esteem and it yes that's a
real challenge for us and I think that's
what we've addressed through our
problem-based learning not every student
gets oh I must say you know not every
student is a Joanna or Nick but all of
our students I think we try to help them
to get to the position where they go yes
I can do that
yes I can take the risks yes I can try
things and I think that's perhaps the
biggest cultural difficulty for us no
I'm just going to ask if that is the
case my agree I agree with you there was
a problem with self-esteem for many many
students and what do you think should
change in schools
I think some of the things that were
said in the last session are really
quite relevant which is if you if you
give a very sort of key performance
indicator based approach to education
where you're telling everyone that if
you haven't done that you've failed so
teachers are failing schools are failing
pupils are failing parents are failing
everybody's failing it's not really
surprising that everybody then looks at
failure is a fairly common thing as
opposed to saying oh it's great we
failed what have we learned
yes and so we haven't got that learning
culture when you change careers advice
as well it's like would you change
careers advice in schools pretty first
job I got given my started teaching was
to take a module on careers advice as a
new graduate and I think it's it's
because I don't honestly don't know how
careers teachers do it
I think careers teachers are in a very
difficult position because I don't know
what careers are are looking forward I
really I don't think anyone can guess
what the careers will be but I think we
still have a lot all that says no there
is a career called engineer I'm not sure
there isn't
I'm not sure these days of it those
careers are necessarily mapped out in
that way can ask Joanna and Nikolas
there aren't enough students like you in
our country doing what you're doing
particularly not enough women in STEM
subjects what would you do to change
that I would do what Middlesex try and
do try and get lots of exposure a lot of
the students that come to events are but
the majority of students that come to
stem are female because we're trying to
push the idea that women in stem is
something that we totally want it's
something that that inequality needs to
be chopped because we perform just as
well as each other so I think the
outreach and showing that it's not just
blokes in a dark room it's more of a
it's a wider experience than that it's a
lot about breaking stereotypes I think
there's there's there's the big series
of the engineers are middle-aged semi
bald men working working in in a room
without windows for hours trade and
engineering it's just classes in my
laptop and it's not engineering is so
much more and if we are able to show
that as a university and and I have so
many girls when we do these outreach
programs coming to me and I'm like oh
isn't it weird being just in the middle
boys or white
do you have any more girls and like well
I will do if you guys come study
engineering and and they sound generally
very very interested in the matter and
just just like me except we perform the
same we are girls we are just as good as
boys are it's just the stereotype in the
stigma I had them many young people
watching this will be inspired by both
of you particularly could I just we're
going to do with a couple of important
questions what do you think and this
probably applies to both of you needs to
happen in terms of adults in terms of
least skilling and upskilling their
occupations or their knowledge given the
arrival of the fourth Industrial
Revolution if I can just add to that
what you think is going to be the impact
for lower skilled adults and what should
we be doing about it so if I if I start
I mean I think the the lifelong learning
question is quite a tricky one and I
think the terms mindset came up earlier
I think I would push it a bit higher
level than that and say I think it's
cultural I think that while we have an
acceptance that ignorance is actually to
be celebrated and I get very tired as a
mathematician hearing people on the
media going oh I could never do maths as
if it's something great than we should
all will love it
or oh yes what I never wanted to be an
engineer you know dirty stuff and I
think we have to somehow I don't know
how we do it but I think if we could get
a culture that said well of course you
carry on learning and some countries do
have that I think where where the idea
that you carry on learning all your life
is not something that sets you apart it
makes you a bit geeky and nerdy it's
just obvious whether what you're
learning is parenting skills whether
what you're learning is grandparenting
skills which I'm discovering are very
different to parenting skills whether
what you're learning is how to
communicate with people across different
generations different cultures we have a
very diverse student body I've learned
so much from working out how I teach
Chinese students and Indian students and
Portuguese students all in the same room
it's a never nothing prepared me for
that in my teacher training so I think
that's the primary thing we need to
change I think if we could do that then
I think we would develop a hunger for
lifelong learning or we could embed it
and people would would embrace it I
think if we if we kind of have it as AI
you need to be retrained because you're
you're not good enough to do what you do
that's your problem I I think we're
never going to win what was the second
second question you are out social
disadvantage in terms yeah I think
that's a really difficult one because I
think it's far from obvious that that
the jobs that we lose will be that the
jobs at the bottom of the tree so to
speak I hate that term but partly
because of economic questions there are
some Delta stylistically not worth
putting a computer in to do a job that
you can take someone on a minimum wage
on a 0 house contract to do is cheaper
to keep a person to do it so I think we
haven't really understood what
technology will change I mean it's quite
likely for example it'll be brain
surgery might be well though this area
yeah some things that I've read suggest
the median jobs and McDonald's might go
worldwide and even now it's not just a
service but it's the burgers that can be
made by yeah to the agency yes that is
and that's perfectly possible the
question is will McDonald's invest in
the infrastructure and the
Najee to do that or will they perpetuate
I think I'm not sure which is a better
outcome to be honest for us obviously
the very nature of Industry for because
it's very much evolving and we're not
we're not we're not quite there yet with
a lot of a lot of technology so it
becomes it comes down to two lifelong
lifelong learning whether it's for the
orab scaling of the of the existing
workforce but it requires a close
collaboration between Fe NH a in terms
of using the right technicians engineers
and one of the C great Institute's to
bring in young graduates 40s or UTC's
which we are very supportive of me I
have the pleasure of being a governor at
UTC Sheffield which is one of the more
very successful ones and it is
unfortunate that the trend now is to to
just say how bad they are but 100%
against against those reports it's also
we are a sponsor of WorldSkills UK which
you're obviously very familiar with that
is an ideal platform venue to to get to
get students and and teachers involve it
I do a lot of stem events we go to a lot
of lot of exhibitions it's not so
difficult with primary kids and their
teachers because by their very nature
they just love asking questions in fact
they tailed they'd like to talk to each
other and asking asking questions and
the teacher goes along with that and
it's just so rewarding to talk to them
you come to come to secondary schools
and it's just the first person to walk
away as a teacher because he's trying to
ask ask a question in case he's
perceived as not not knowing the latest
technology and then with that students
all all all dispersed at the skills show
forget about some 70 80 thousand
students who walk through and you see
over a three-day period for a lot of
them there is there is no if they come
from a college yes they're fine if the
computer sees they seem to have an
agenda to what to look for but if they
come from schools it's just like the
matrix therefore it's just a day out but
if the teacher spends some time with
them to say when we go there these are
the
I mean you've got all these large
employers there I mean it's not a joke
to our BAE Systems Jaguar Land Rover you
name it they're there these are the
joints of Industry I mean go and talk to
them go and find out what the later
skills what you need to do what are the
job opportunities so there should be
some mechanism that these youngsters
they come back with with some some some
valuable data and unfortunately it's not
it's not there well thank you to the
humans on the panel especially the
students some as I understand it it's
the first time that we've ever had a
nonhuman appear as I'll select committee
although there may be a lot of people in
the media might argue otherwise but I
thank you thank you for coming today
pepper thank you very much for an
interesting discussion and for the
opportunity to give evidence to the
committee today thank you and work very
well done to Middlesex a wonderful
University
Education Committee 16th October
Thatcher ooh
Education Committee 16th of October
Thatcher ooh
Education Committee 16th October touch
Arun
Education Committee 16th of October
Thatcher ooh
Education Committee 16th of October
Satoru
Education Committee 60